hallo hier ist wieder eure mal wanne und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge sein
willst es stimmt wir lärm zum
wissenschaftler denn ich habe einen
vulkanausbruch gekauft calabro und
schals diesem laden gesehen habe dass
ich so ok ja klar ist natürlich absolut
aber halt wir sehen noch nicht aus dem
wissenschaftler
das müssen wir ändern ok ja ich glaub
ich hätte auch als pflegerin durchgehen
aber tomate tomaten
thomasius
thomas also erstmal sind hier so mehr
die chemischen sachen die man dafür
braucht drin natrium hydrogencarbonat
und farbstoff und kalium geologen
phosphat wow zwei teile eines vulkans
dorf ist klein aber gut was habe ich
erwartet eine pipette und ein mix gerät
die bedienungsanleitung stehen hier erst
mal telefonnummern der
giftnotrufzentrale also falls man das zu
wissen
die grundregel fürs experimentieren
trudel flaschen effekt ihr könnt das
wahrscheinlich nicht lesen aber das
steht versuch 1-studie flaschen effekt
schiffl eine sprudelflasche und öffnen
sie dann wie ein vulkanausbruch ob mein
gott es mir schon ziemlich offen für
karl ausgebrochen ist kompliziert
bevor ich vergesse ich habe ein comedy
market mit dabei und zwar durfte ich in
drei sketchen mitdrehen zweiten online
auf ihrem kanal ich verliere euch das
mal hier und für die leute die ein handy
benutzen mache ich euch hier mal dieses
in brand
ihr könnt ihr mal auf dem kanal geht und
den abonnieren die machen halt echt
lustige nen scheiß und guckt euch meine
sketche also die mädchen die sind echt
was dich geworden
und wenn ihr den kanal seit grüßt man
den daniele rizzo garantie von mir und
sagte dass er dürfte es aber jetzt
konzentrieren wir uns wieder auf und
seine vulkan die bahn einen teller
wissen ja doch dieser schale machen
allerdings so classic schutz apparat ist
aufbaut
ich brauche nur noch was wir machen
sollen
alles drei ein bisschen von farbstoff
rühren und wasser auf und dann ist es
schon zu weit amerikanischen film
gesehen dass sie dann halt ja in ihren
experimenten die sie machen wollten
haben sie immer vulkanausbrüche hardware
ist
deutsche schulen gehen ist es egal ich
um ein bisschen wasser
jetzt arbeiten wir mit chemikalien
da brauchen wir sicherheits brille ok
komplett rein das ist unser karl jung
hydrogen phosphor und jetzt kommt's
natrium carbon dass staub keine erbsen
große menge
die große nicht gewalt nur richtig
richtig
ok nächstes mal zusammen
so
ich soll jetzt die komplette mit wasser
einfüllen und rühren denn bereich okay
seht ihr das mal von nahm diese wohl
erwartet ein bisschen aus wie er keine
wirkung mehr weiß ich ob ich wenn ich
acht wäre es mir besser gefallen würde
stimmt schon das internet hat es einfach
versorgt wir finden nichts mehr
wir müssen noch cocktail sind ganz fans
bisschen baby aus diesem video doch noch
das beste machen
tschüss und willst du nicht mal und
tschüss